in this video amongst other experimental
camera tests i attach my camera and this
mini crane to a 60 meter rope and throw
it off a building
before getting into this video i'd just
like to remind you that this channel is
not coming to an end just yet i'll still
be uploading 15 videos and then i'll be
taking a long break when directing my
first feature film cool back to the
video
you know what i don't like
gimbals here's why besides making the
fluid shot overused without
understanding the reason why one would
use this technique so just gets thrown
into every single montage scene possible
which in turn creates the death of the
beautifully considered handheld shots
they also take time to set up and
balance they are finicky usually big and
fragile and lastly overpriced however
this is my current opinion i have to
remain open-minded because i haven't
used a gimbal until now until
this gimbal seems to fix most problems
i've had with gimbals on the market
introducing the zion crane m3 a compact
easy to use gimbal that supports most
cameras from a cell phone all the way to
a full-frame mirrorless camera
comes in this nifty bag along with a
variety of accessories
included is a full quarter inch jack
input base plates for every setup you
have cables that connect your camera to
the crane for more functionality and
snap-on magnetic filters to change the
color of the light
but i'm still not convinced about where
to use it can it perform more than just
the fluid movement shot so what i've
decided to do is put this little piece
of gear to the test and recreate three
of my favorite but very expensive shots
from big budget hollywood movies
the first scene being this very
impressive opening sequence from
limitless
[Music]
this is obviously cg and can be achieved
with an fpv drone but i'm going to be
making use of rope
the crane and
my cell phone let's do this
[Music]
okay so it turns out the elevator the
ritz hotel isn't working therefore luke
and i are gonna have to walk up 20
floors to get to the roof in order to
get this shot
let's go
okay so what we're gonna do is test with
the rope how far we should go before the
camera hits the ground each one of these
ropes are 30 meters long this building
is 66 meters high so we're gonna have to
tie three together
jeremy we are about to send the rope
down copy that
okay here it goes
[Music]
okay so what we're gonna do is take the
zion crane m3 balance it with the camera
put it on the end of the rope and down
we go the theory is
that this is going to spin like that and
the phone's going to stay in the same
place and we're going to be able to get
that shot
yeah i'm just headed down to the bottom
floor so i can be in the shot
catching the camera as it gets to the
ground
okay cool i'm in position luke's all the
way up there luke
you're ready to go in five seconds
so the next shot you're gonna see is
from my iphone on the crane
let's go
[Music]
oh i got it
rad on to the next one okay let's go
now i'm going to try and recreate this
scene from children of men
obviously without the angry mob but
specifically the camera movement 360
rotation within the car which was made
with this really expensive and
complicated rig i'm going to recreate
this really simply by using these straps
i've already balanced the iphone on wide
mode
[Music]
okay that was a much bigger mission than
i thought it would be but along with the
amazing stabilization of the zion it
should look pretty good okay now for the
scene i've got three of my friends rain
luke and jeremy and i'm going to rotate
the crane with my phone as we pass
around the popcorn it also has this
light which will help light up our faces
as it rotates pretty cool
okay
okay that fold good let's see what it
looks like
[Music]
okay for the third crane m3 test we're
going back to limitless the movie to try
and recreate the scene
[Music]
the scene is slightly more complex to
recreate i've got a mirror a very large
mirror luke will be
talent in the scene the green screen
and i've got to move through three
different scenarios and if we do it
right all we'll have to do is just
stagger the shots
[Music]
okay rad let's see what that looks like
[Music]
cool
looks like i found a place for the zion
crane m3 after all and it'll easily fit
in my camera bag because it's so small
i'll be using it mainly with the sony
a7c which just feels like the perfect
fit along with the 60 millimeter lens as
well as you can go on to their sites and
just check out if your current camera is
compatible with the crane it really does
work with a wide variety of cameras and
if you would like to purchase one i've
linked them in the description below
please let me know what you thought
about this video in the comments below
as well as subscribe and turn your
notifications below on other than that
don't forget you're awesome bruh and
i'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she